have you ever felt a little bit of
anxiety a little bit of fear when it
comes to speaking your target language
for the first time for example you
imagine that even before and start
talking everything is going to go wrong
you don't know what to say your mind
goes blank you don't understand what the
other person says to you you feel judged
you think you're making a lot of
mistakes well if that has happened to
you first
it's totally normal and second you are
in the right video speaking a foreign
language looks like a very natural act
but then when it comes to speaking it
might be a little bit daunting so let me
give you six fundamental rules of thumb
or tips to make you a great communicator
in any language and stay tuned because
there's going to be one super extra cool
tip at the end of the video learning
anything is strictly connected with
emotions if you walk into a conversation
in a foreign language with the right
state of mind your levels of dopamine
will be higher and when your dopamine is
high he will be able to listen better
engage better speak better be a better
communicator so always remember that the
very first factor for impressive and
effective communication is actually your
state of mind always walk into a
conversation with a positive state of
mind and thinking I'm going to learn I'm
going to enjoy this conversation I'm
going to get my point across communicate
with another human being that will make
a huge difference instead of telling
yourself I'm going to be judged I'm
making mistakes and you will see what
difference it makes when that really
happens
your future your success when it comes
to speaking 1 2 3 4 languages is not
defined but the assumptions you have
provided that you get rid of them and
one cool thing that you can do is to
take a piece of paper use pencil because
it always works focus on that piece of
paper and think about all the
assumptions and only bad experiences
that you have when it comes to speaking
and do tabula rasa start from scratch
and project yourself into the future
with a positive mindset you are going to
be a great communicator
if you want to building a solid mindset
it's not just a matter of finding a
piece of paper joining down stuff and
convincing that everything is going to
go well you have to make it happen what
is the best way to make something like
this happen well just find a native
speaker to talk to the internet offers
us a lot of possible it is nowadays you
can go to numerous websites where you
can just write the profile send a
message and get into a conversation with
some now what do you want to do and this
is key and absolutely crucial is to find
a person with whom you're going to
cooperate with with whom you're going to
learn from and they're going to learn
from you and the key word here is
cooperation through cooperation you're
going to reinforce strengthen your
mindset and you want to find someone
who's understanding who's on the same
wavelength probably has similar
interests and hobbies so the
conversations have to be enjoyable if
you enjoy the conversation you're going
to focus on communication and that is
key to hone and improve your speaking
skills
[Music]
so I started coaching the student of
mine and then he told me something that
really kind of shocked me and surprised
me he told me that every time that he
started having a speaking session with
his teacher the teacher told him wait a
second let's do some grammar stuff or
let's go through some reading out loud
and I told myself what when you speak
the foreign language be it with your
tutor your teacher your language tandem
your friends always make sure that you
talk about what you want to talk about
because if you enjoy something you will
learn your levels of dopamine will arise
and you will be more attentive so a very
simple technique is to jot down and
brainstorm about all the things you
really want to talk about before having
this conversation so you're gonna jump
directly into the conversation knowing
what you're going to say and you're
going to enjoy the conversation
when something really cool happens to
what is it do you want to do immediately
think about it you want to talk about it
to someone so imagine for example that
something really cool happened in the
afternoon and a night you're sitting
with your friends at a bar and you're
telling them about the story when you
were excited about something you'd want
to say everything you hear about making
mistakes you'll hear about the details
of the language you're just going for it
you don't think about the language the
tool through which you're communicating
you're just using it and when you do
that in a foreign language you're
learning as a consequence of that always
walk in a conversation thinking that
something really cool happened to you
and you really want to talk about it and
so make language learning a consequence
of communicating of getting your point
across of telling compelling stories of
being yourself telling about yourself
telling about what happened in your life
that will make a huge difference because
it's a paradigm shift it shifts the
focus from language where you think
about being judged and making mistakes
to communication we're just getting the
point across and you're learning as a
consequence of that let's go back to
school just for a second and imagine
that the teacher is asking you to talk
about something what is it that happens
so think about it for a second you tend
to stay within your comfort zone you
tend to say only what you can say and it
only makes sense right it would be weird
to stumble and ask a guys or the teacher
herself or himself hey do you know the
word because I can't continue if I don't
know the world but that's exactly what
you have to do with your landing
language tandem or when you're learning
a language independently you have to be
curious you have to ask remember the
point before you're getting your point
across and sometimes we stumble upon a
pieces of information that we simply
don't know we didn't know how to say
them in the language so just ask for
help get out of your comfort zone means
putting yourself in a situation where
you're going to learn as a consequence
of that so when you tackle a topic that
you've never tackled before and when you
having a conversation with your language
tandem just ask them how do you say this
how do you say that and learn as a
consequence of that when you get out of
your comfort zone it means that you're
learning and that's what you have to do
so here you have it with these few
simple tips you can literally
revolutionize your approach your
strategies your techniques to speak
better and speak more confidently if you
want to know more how to be a better
communicator please click on the link in
the description box below there's going
to be a lot of more additional
information techniques strategies in
other languages as well you just name it
so please head over the blog and join
the community so as usual I have one
question and one cool extra tip for you
at the end of the video let's start with
the question what are the things that
really work well for you when it comes
to speaking of foreign language both
psychologically and linguistically
please leave comments below and let's
make this conversation constructive and
useful for everyone since you've been
patient until now let me reward you with
one cool extra bit simplicity is beauty
and beauty is simplicity this applies to
language learning as well when it comes
to interacting with another person make
sure that you use simple words simple
sentences go straight to the point the
fact that you're using simple language
actually allows you brain to think
directly in the target language so get
simple be simple and be an effective
communicator it will make a huge
difference get into the habit of getting
your point across with very simple words
[Music]